what's going on guys this is rob and a
lot of you all have been asking me to
cover dear becky uh which is basically
the continuation of the boys series not
in the traditional sense two things that
i want to make clear here the first is
that this will have spoilers for the
boys so if you don't want to have
anything spoiled for you then as much as
i hate to say it
turn the video off now granted this is
spoilers for the boys comic so the tv
show may be entirely different there's a
few things about the show right off the
bat that look like they're different
what they're gonna do with black noir i
don't know i'm kind of hoping we get the
comic book thing but i don't know if we
will but regardless uh that's the whole
thing there right so you may end up
getting some spoilers here just fyi the
second thing if you are a parent and you
hear me talking right now do not let
your child watch this video
[Laughter]
because this is not for the kitties i've
done my part now uh if your child
watches this video anyway do not get mad
at me get mad at yourself for being a
bad parent so here's the thing what this
does is this initially opens up with
basically huey in scotland now for those
of you guys who remember from the boys
that was kind of the conclusion of it
all right the huey and and annie ended
up getting together and they took off to
scotland and presumably just lived
happily ever after or as happily ever
after as you can get after all the stuff
that they went through during the boys
series but uh you have huey here who's
having a conversation with a friend of
his body now because this takes place 12
years later this is around 2020 or so
and so what this means is a lot of the
current culture going on right now is a
point of discussion here and that's one
of the things that garth anders always
focus on in his comics right those are
the guys who are familiar with garth
ennis's writing he doesn't shy away from
ruffling feathers right and in all
honesty he's not really wrong people
need to be offended from time to time if
for no other reason than it reminds them
their viewpoint is not the absolute
right viewpoint despite what their echo
chamber will tell them and two they're
not as important as they think they are
and so it's a kind of a necessity in
society kind of a correction a societal
correction that happens to thomas time
and so garth dennis was was always a
proponent of that and one of the first
things that he talks about here is again
like this idea of woke culture and it's
kind of funny because you have this
conversation between huey and his friend
bobby who's a transgender woman and the
idea of of woke culture from huey's
perspective is he's like it's a load of
crap is what it is right it's just white
folk inventing ways to feel like they're
making a difference before they screw
off to the suburbs and start you know
spitting out a whole bunch of kids which
is kind of true we as a society as
people we we come across things that we
deem to be absolutely important right
especially in our 20s we're like this is
an exceedingly important thing and then
a magical thing happens we turn 30 and
we have kids families we have a house
we've got bills that need to be paid and
suddenly those things that were the most
important things ever because there was
really nothing else that seemed as
important stop being important because
we have other things that are more
important right it's just kind of the
way things are so again it's just one of
those those things that go on with
society as a whole but they kind of
debate back and forth one thing to
understand do not misconstrue the
relationship between hoey i'm sorry huey
and bobby i don't know why i called him
hoey
let's call him hoey from now on uh do
not misconstrue the relationship between
the two i am not from scotland as i
understand it like friendly conversation
friendly banter between people from
scotland we in the states would consider
to be kind of offensive right because
we're so soft as people out there
they're a lot more intense right they
are a lot more just kind of whatever
just tell you what's on their mind that
kind of a thing more brash in their
conversation style so while people well
we may look at it and say damn man those
guys must hate each other they're being
dicks the reality is that it's just kind
of how they converse amongst each other
and i you know honestly i take garth
thanos's word for a word for it as far
as i'm aware he is scottish so he's kind
of rooted in that culture which is why
he's able to write the characters in
such an interesting way but one of the
things that happens of course is of
course you know with huey being a friend
of bobby and while it is really more of
just a general conversation kind of
friendly banter back and forth really
more of a debate than anything else when
they get to the bartender that guy is a
prick he's like dude i hope you guys
like i pray every single night you guys
catch covet 19 and die i hope you get
cancer of the dick it's just like dude
this guy's awful man but it's but the
the overall gist of this conversation
though and this is one of the things
that's so cool right once you get past
the things that you're looking to find
that will offend you you can actually
look at it as a greater whole and you
come to this realization that it's a
very somber conversation between the two
because one of the things that they talk
about here one of the things they kind
of discuss is that with everything going
on huey himself hasn't quite asked annie
to marry him yet and she kind of seems
to be sort of coasting along with the
idea as well at least that's the whole
perception she puts off but he can't
really bring himself to do it just
because of the things that he's
experienced the things he's seen and the
reality is the two of them can't really
have kids either things that had gone on
with them when they were younger now
this isn't garth in a saying like any
woman who cannot have children is not a
woman worth marrying that's not really
what he said what he's saying here is
that for the two of them taking the
traditional approach you know the kind
of old-fashioned approach to
relationships which is to say you know
boy meets girl boy meets boy girl meets
girl whatever and you date each other
for a little while basically to see
whether or not you like each other and
then after that year or so of liking
each other you usually move in and
that's a test run to see whether or not
a marriage actually works right can you
tolerate the other person's existence in
such close quarters
do they snore do they fart obnoxiously
just different things like that and if
at the end of that test run you come to
the realization that i can tolerate this
person living with me sleeping in my bed
or sleeping in the same bed or what have
you then you get married and you do that
hopefully for the rest of your life uh
the reality here is that traditional
stance doesn't really apply to them
because kids can't necessarily be part
of the equation they've come from some
pretty traumatic experiences from their
own personal experiences as well as the
kind of things they dealt with right you
guys remember the whole idea of annie in
the seven that that she idolized the
seven she believed the seven were like
just heroes now that's because she was a
simple farm girl from back in des moines
where life was basic and she didn't
really understand how the world actually
worked so when she got there to the
seven she was presented with a choice
either she could engage in sexual
intercourse with the guys who were in
the seven or she could not be on the
team and she chose to engage in sexual
intercourse so she could be on the team
uh it rocked her to her core right the
choice she made was a choice that she
ended up regretting but at the end of
the day it was still a choice she made
and that affected her on a personal
level you move that into the territory
of realizing just how dark and sinister
things are when it comes to the seven in
this world right that the heroes that
she believed were heroes are actually
just people who were corrupted by their
own celebrity status it just totally
changed the way she saw everything and
it made her pretty dark and so with huey
it's very similar right coming across
this really dark and twisted world and
the kind of things he did when he was
part of the boys it really changed him
and so looking at those kinds of things
you know the question that he kind of
asks here is do i even want like even if
i could have kids would i want to bring
them into this world right because the
conversation transitions over to you
know i guess the ocean or whatever it is
but like they're on a beach right having
this this this whole thing and as
they're talking about this idea of like
the seven and vaude american and how
like you know it all seemed to kind of
come crashing down in the sense of like
the superheroes and the world's
perception of them and all that kind of
stuff right that the the boys kind of
serve their purpose here that in the end
the agreement they come to is it's not
really going to do any good and the
reason why is because the seven were
just a symptom right the seven became
what they were because at their core
they were people and as people who are
inherently flawed is people who are
inherently broken again garth ennis is
very much a cynic and that's one of the
things like the boys perfectly
highlighted his cynicism that when you
when he looked at people it was kind of
like people are screwed up right you
don't like like the human race doesn't
need superheroes to destroy the world
just look at the state of the world
right like the kovid 19 pandemic hit in
the boys universe and like the entire
world shut down giving no thought to
what would actually happen when they did
and then when the whole world was shut
down nothing was being produced or
anything like that and then suddenly the
world was open back up and the most
logical scenario happened the economy
just went into almost free fall there
was a just total freezing up of
virtually every resource across like
literally nothing was available
everything became ultra expensive
because of scarcity like it's just the
result of people doing things and giving
no thought to what they're doing right
they talk about climate change half the
world is on fire nobody really cares
right i mean because it's not affecting
them on a personal level it's a very
very you know cynical perspective of
humanity people screwed up the world not
superheroes and so it's one of those
interesting things where it really is
just kind of a damning critique of
humanity and so once huey gets back home
what he ends up discovering is basically
a package that's been delivered to his
house now of course he ends up going and
sitting on the john as we all do right
you know whether it's our phones or
books whatever the case is reading
material it's necessary i don't know
about you guys sometimes i sit so long
that my leg goes numb so when i stand up
like i feel like i don't have a leg
surely i'm not the only one who
experiences that right i'm not the only
one out there who loses the ability to
walk after sitting on a toilet for too
long but the thing about this is as he
goes through this this journal this
diary he realizes it belongs to becky
butcher the wife of billy butcher and
for whatever reason it's been sent to
him more so than that what he discovers
here and it seems to have been sitting
here intentionally because there's a
whole journal entry in here where billy
butcher basically wrote a letter to
becky and so that's where things are
interesting is because what you get here
is this really interesting monologue by
billy himself right he says dear becky i
feel a bit strange writing to you like
this i feel even stranger writing in
your diary because it's something that
belonged to you i've never i never even
knew that you had it but it was yours
when i read what was in it i went
completely blood spare i've never been
more angry in my life but it's something
that was yours and even touching it
makes me feel the grounds moving under
my feet because you're gone and so it's
one of those things where as he's kind
of addressing this and discussing this
you know huey sort of shies away from it
now one of the things to know and the
reason why he kind of reacts the way he
does is because billy butcher scared the
hell out of huey right that's one of the
most important things to understand that
billy butcher as you see him in the show
it's pretty accurate to the comics in
the comics he had i think a little more
of a darker sense of humor than what you
see in the in the tv show but they're
not that dissimilar and unlike huey as
you see him in the tv show sure he's got
conviction and he's got a kind of
strength of character in a lot of ways
huey was very very cowardly not in every
way but in a lot of ways and what this
meant was that billy butcher just being
this dominating force over huey in a lot
of ways scared the hell out of him so
huey's ptsd comes just as much from
billy butcher as it does anybody else in
reading this diary of becky this letter
that billy butcher wrote to becky kind
of scares huey because it's like what if
billy butcher catches me right because
billy butcher was always there always
kind of lingering around the corner he
would show up when you would least
expect it so that kind of fear still
sticks with huey in a lot of ways and so
what he says is he says you know people
of course would be surprised to learn
that i could read and write at the same
time he says but you would never have
said anything like that right you were
the only one that really and truly
believed in me god help you he says you
were the only one in the whole bloody
world i could talk to and you still are
because this is the only way that i can
think of to do this because i think
maybe you're not gone you know he says i
know that you're not lingering over my
shoulder right watching me or anything
like that he's like i mean something
else and so what this does is it really
transitions into this idea that in a lot
of ways becky is with billy butcher in
so far that she's his conscience right
she is the conscience that kind of keeps
him in check that keeps him from going
too far down the path because one of the
things to remember is that a lot of what
billy butcher does is a result of the
death of becky by the fact that becky
died the way she was again becky was
basically sexually assaulted by black
noir even though it was believed to have
been homelander and then of course she
died when that just weird super powered
baby came out of her literally blew a
hole through with his heat vision and
like and she died right she was killed
and so billy butcher always harbored
that as the reason why superheroes have
to go because when that happened it was
all swept under the rug right nobody
knew billy butcher was like the only one
who really knew and it was like so long
as companies like vault of autumn
american exist out there and superheroes
are allowed to operate with impunity
this will never change right what we
have to do is inject accountability into
an uh a system that completely and
totally lacks it now one of the things i
also want to specify is this little bit
right here with this younger kid this
takes place before huey comes on the
scene so this is kind of that period
that interim period following billy
butcher's desire to basically destroy
the superhero community or at least
bring it down uh and before huey joins
in so we're talking about the history of
billy butcher here and one of the things
that we get is that they've basically
tracked down this younger kid now we
will find out exactly what's going on
with him we'll find out why it is
they're here in the first place but
quite literally one of the things to
remember is that the boys was brutal
those are guys who never read the boys
comic we did the uncensored version on
patreon but we did the censored version
here even the censored version was kind
of stretching it a little bit the
uncensored version was insane but when
it comes to the boys themselves it was a
brutal story the way in which they would
go after heroes right the way that they
would blackmail whatever it is they had
to do they didn't care it was whatever
it is they needed to do they get to get
the information they wanted or to take
out whoever they needed to this is a
perfect example of that because what
happens is this tongue gets pulled out
of this mouth and it's literally held in
place by the female and then billy
butcher with the razor blade cuts it off
and so obviously right off the bat you
know that like this kid's power has to
do with his ability to speak the way
this is kind of explained to us is that
while they're sort of going back and
forth and having this discussion billy
just of course is always being billy
right it's always like okay so like
we've basically taken care of this kid
what's the next one right what's the
next target mallory like again mallory
leads the team at this point in time
that's one of the things to remember is
that by the time the boys series had
picked up mallory was out of the picture
and it was just billy butcher leading
the boys and in a lot of ways that's
where things kind of went off the rails
that mallory was able to provide a
direction for the team like here are the
people that we're going after we're
doing it strategically and each and
every person that we target it serves a
greater purpose when mallory was out of
the picture and it was just billy
butcher leading the team it seemed all
bets were off and billy's just like
we're hitting every last one of them
right all i care about is achieving that
particular goal the kind of finesse that
mallory brought to the scene the sort of
organization and structure that mallory
had was completely lacking and so that's
why the boys team under billy butcher
seemed more chaotic it seemed more just
kind of all over the place no real rhyme
or reason no structure organization or
anything like that and under mallory it
was a lot more organized and structured
and so again billy butcher just kind of
being billy butcher here what we find
out is this is all a front right this is
all kind of a facade to a degree right
that what happens is like in the midst
of all that that you end up having this
kid who basically starts just shouting
this word now obviously with a lack of a
tongue it's difficult to make out you
can put the pieces together if this kid
had a tongue he'd be saying shazam so
obviously this is a play on billy batson
that's one of the things to remember for
those of you guys who never read the
boys all the various depictions of the
superheroes you see are pastiches of
existing superheroes it's basically
garth innis answering the question what
if like superman and wonder woman and
the flash and these guys were corrupted
by their own popularity their own
celebrity status right that's sort of a
thing uh so obviously this kid is just
trying to say shazam but doesn't have a
tongue his powers don't work but you
switch back over to this letter that
billy's writing to becky and he says so
i'm standing there looking at him or it
even i don't know and i don't really see
people with powers as being people
anymore but he says i'm watching it
stand there and spit and just trying to
kill us with how much it absolutely
hates us and i'm thinking yeah this is
them right this is what superheroes are
actually like this isn't what the the
what bot american shows the world joe
averages perception of heroes right the
positive slant this is who they really
are right this is the the version of
heroes how these people actually are
that only me and the boys really know
about and he says this is what makes it
easy for me he says but the next thing i
know i'm thinking of something else and
this is becky basically coming in as
kind of the conscience of billy butcher
and he says there's no way i'm going to
say this to mallory and any of the other
boys but no matter what he's done no
matter that he says his stupid bloody
word and gets five times bigger and then
basically just starts assaulting people
in a variety of different ways he's
still just a ten-year-old kid and i know
why it is that i'm thinking that and the
reason why he's thinking that is because
that's becky that's his conscience
saying he's just a ten-year-old right
he's just a little kid he doesn't know
any better this kid never had a chance
and so he says i hate talking about
supes and all this this stuff with you
but if you're with me in the way that i
think you are then you see it all anyway
he says you're still there becky all the
good stuff that you've done for me and
got me to believe about myself that's
you and i don't know why but i feel like
you're getting stronger and that you're
not going anywhere at least not anytime
soon and he says but you see i just
can't have that because the way things
are looking with the soups they're going
to get worse which means the things that
i'll have to do are going to get worse
and so he says god forgive me but i
think that what i've got to do is kill
you now again he's not talking about
killing becky literally she's already
dead what he's talking about doing is
killing his conscience killing that part
of him that speaks up and says you can't
do this kind of stuff right i mean
they're just a 10 year old kid or that
person didn't know any better or they're
so young or that person can be redeemed
killing that part of himself and this is
huge because it explains how it is that
billy butcher got to the point when we
first meet him in the beginning of the
boys where he spares no morality when it
comes to superheroes where he's like
they're all the same every single
superhero out there is the exact same
they don't get any benefit of the doubt
they don't get any kind of morality or
anything like that it's they are there
for a purpose and when that purpose is
served if they live to see the dawn it's
because i allowed and that's basically
it so with that being said guys this is
the first issue we still got seven more
to go let me know i thought about doing
this on a weekly basis where we just
cover it every you know one one episode
every week that's what we're gonna be
doing with the kang series and that's
what we're doing with the dark prices
series from dc so let me know if you
want to do the same thing here or if you
want me to just push it all through
through the whole week and then we just
kind of cover stuff intermittently in
between let me know what you guys think
but with that being said we're going to
bring this to an end and i will catch
you all later
peace
you